welcome everybody to another Google
hangout super excited to be here with a
friend of mine Anton and we're gonna be
talking about how to write ads that sell
so you don't need to hire a copywriter
and you know writing great content is
one of the things that you need to do as
an entrepreneur to get your message out
and to get people to buy your stuff so
Anton is the man
Anton welcome to the show thanks I'm
really glad to be here
cool do you want to give people just a
quick intro a little background on you
so they know where you're coming from
yes so um I've been writing copy which
is writing ads for mostly online
entrepreneurs for almost I'd say four to
five years at this point it's been all
I've been doing for a long time I have
my name isn't out there so much because
I like to hide in the shadows I I've
worked for some people that you may have
heard of I've worked for raw meats 80
for a while as a senior copywriter and
probably a lot of other people that you
may not have heard of and I also spent a
lot of time working on my own background
business because I like I really I I do
copywriting because really at heart I'm
an entrepreneur that's what I love so
you know I spent a lot of time working
on my Amazon business and all sorts of
other stuff in the background that's my
little story cool and I put his link to
the website below you guys can learn
more about what he's all about - so
let's you know hit me up with some tips
so what do I need to know I want to
write some ads that sell what's what's
your process what advice do you have for
entrepreneurs okay so walk with me for a
second let's just last week I was on
Facebook I have an old friend he's a
magician and he doesn't know anything
about writing coffee he doesn't know how
do I copy like he doesn't spend time
reading books like me and all that crap
he doesn't he doesn't know what to do
okay but he did a really good job I was
impressed I was so impressed I called
him up because I hadn't talked to him in
a good few years I called know that's
how much
coffee and he's used this technique to
really grow his business to the next
level he just told me he actually might
be he's he's fingers crossed he's trying
to do a show for Justin Bieber in a
couple of weeks that's where he's at
okay so um so I'm gonna tell you
something that I saw on his Facebook so
I just puts up a video and he says uh
just a story about some mistakes that I
made you know and then I watch the video
and it's all about this story about how
right before one of one of his big gigs
as a magician he has to go to the
bathroom and what happens is he
accidentally goes to the ladies bathroom
and he's it's really like a bad time
he's a really embarrassed everybody's
looking at him like he's a freak show
and what's going on I don't want to do
and then from there he everything that
could go wrong went wrong and he really
had to grapple with I pull up the best
all of the stops as being the
professional that he is to ensure that
he had a great show and he was worried
because for a second that really looked
like it might not work out and they
might not be happy but he was like hey I
have my money back guarantee blah blah
blah and that was this video okay so I
gave you this example for a really
really important reason I summarized
this I hope you caught the idea but the
reason I told you this is because one of
what I'd say is the biggest mistakes
that people are making with copying how
to persuade people how to sell is that
they're thinking a little bit too much
like elect like a professor and not
enough like someone who's sitting on a
bar having a good time with someone like
a friend okay so the bottom line here is
nobody likes a lecture and everybody
loves a good story right and the more
you lecture the more you're gonna have
to pull out all of the the fancy stuff
to make your your ad sound amazing and
the more you tell a good story the less
selling you have to do the less
high-pressure
you have to be the less sleazy and slimy
you sound so the first step is tell a
good story that's I'm gonna like land
that plane and that's that's the first
big tip tell a good story and embedding
your the benefits to your service and
product in a damn good story
cool so if I'm you know so all here's an
example so one of the business I have is
a salsa dancing business okay so yeah so
say I'm writing copy for the home page
or the about page write what
how would you lead off with a story what
what store do I want to tell to entice
people to want to sign up for salsa
classes okay I would start with one of a
couple things um if first of all I would
tell a story that answers a few
important questions
why are you better why are you different
what makes you better what's what what
is it about salsa that really could get
someone excited alright and then I would
find a story that you can tell that is
your story Evan that exemplifies what it
is that all of these questions that you
just now answered right so you Evan
I don't remember I don't know your life
as a salsa dancer or instructor or owner
of a salsa business but I know that you
know I remember the last one of the
times in the past that we spoke he told
a story about how you sold your business
and you were just you know kind of like
a college kid and oh so long ago I still
kind of remember how that's how you were
struggling and it sucked and here you
are now right so I can't I I obviously
can't tell the story for you cuz I
didn't notice
I gotta have to find it out of you and
if you could find a way as a salsa
dancer to say it it almost it almost has
thinking about a client I worked with
long ago who was working was kind of a
weight-loss product and we're told a
story about how the guy lost his
girlfriend to some guy who was blatantly
just like hot right and I had a
beautiful six packing that was like
where he was at right and so you could
tell a story about how you Evan you know
really your life got changed for salsa
right and if you tell it in a way that
the people feel like wow my life could
change from salsa right I actually as
you see that I you know cuz I do do that
dance salsa reminds me of a friend of
mine who salsa to her was almost like
therapy right so she was a survivor of a
lot of abuse but I'm not really sure
what kind of abuse but it was a very
traumatic past that she came from and so
she had no confidence
she stayed alone at home and then she
started doing salsa and not only did she
get better but she had all of these
friends and that's what salsa did for
her so that's kind of like an example
just look that's off of my head cool so
do you recommend that entrepreneurs then
tell their own story or tell other
people's stories or client stories or
mixture of both and and how do you
prioritize you know you got your home
page most important thing has to go
there
yeah the easiest but but how do you
prioritize what to put up okay so this
is very um there are different places
and ways you want to speak to your
customer across different mediums so now
we're talking about a website we could
be talking about a sales page for like a
higher-end product we could be talking
about an email funnel right and um you
know your story for your sales page
could be really just a summary of the
longer story right it could be you
I have a you know III teach success tips
and I used to stand in line at the you
know the food bank to get groceries and
now here I am and I you know have the
lifestyle lifestyle I choose and I can
do something and that could be the whole
story it could be just an introductory
video and you don't even have to go into
the long details because maybe you might
save that for something like a more
in-depth product right so you could say
hi my name is Evan Carmichael and
welcome to my website on this website I
teach people about how to grow their
businesses and how to make it from
scratch all the way to success whatever
that means for you I myself came from a
place where not too long ago I was just
like you I was struggling trying to find
my way I was just 19 and I couldn't I
could barely get my bills paid I had to
work 80 hours a week just to survive it
was struggle after struggle and trial
and tribulation a lot of people can
really relate to this fight because we
had been there I mean but I was probably
closer to that lifestyle back when I
spoke to you years ago but anyway and
Here I am now I have a YouTube channel
with 250 subscribers I have a website
with a million people a month or
whatever I have a an email list with
honey I don't know how I don't know what
you know and I learned a lot of things
along the way and this is what I want to
teach you please join my email list and
we'll talk or join my list and I'll give
you that the first step and whatever the
first step is I don't know
cool um so we got some live questions
coming in Timor is asking I pronounce
that okay where's the line between
strict formal and down-to-earth
copywriting okay oh I love that question
because it's probably the download the
list of like the third filter that I
look at copy from is is this
stiff and not well I'll tell you
actually the simple the the the way that
I would put it is I would reflect back
to the customer the language that they
themselves use okay and that's not an
easy thing to do like if you are not in
touch with their customers so the the
the answer to your question is figure
get in touch with your customers which
by itself is something that I would be
happy to really give you some good
insight on but reflect your cut reflect
the language of your customer so if your
customer is you know a blue-collar
worker and they typically say howdy
right maybe you want to greet them like
howdy I remembered this internet
marketer who you know they always signed
off as cousin whatever the name was
right hey see you later from cousin Andy
or whatever the name was right and it's
like you want to reflect the language of
your customer and you don't want to go
above up a little bit so if your
customer is a venture capitalist and
they speak with a lot of jargon and
that's their world I still want to I
select it err on the side of simple
simplistic language because at the end
of the day that simple language works
but reflect the language of the customer
yeah I think that too that too it's also
who you are and still answer anyway
right like like if I'm trying to sell to
somebody who is really formal and then I
get really formal and then they look at
my other stuff that's not formal there's
gonna be a huge rise connect and so
matching both like understand who your
customers are and how they speak and how
they want to be connected to and then
also take that information do
something's congruent with who you are
so that you feel comfortable and natural
especially if you end up doing like
video and or interviews where you have
to you know it'd be hard for me to go
and do a video like I'm rocking a hat
and the hoodie you know like yeah you
know like you gotta put me in the tuxedo
and like you got to be very formal you
can't see yeah yeah let be rough for me
that yeah I mean I remember I went I was
giving out an award in an event
I I it was a black-tie thing and I
showed up with my hoodie dress pants
dress pants but my honey man that's you
know they can kick me out if they want
but I'm being here too so I think I
think it's both I think it's like
matching you the customer then also
thinking about who you are as a person
making that congruent I think I think
I'll wait to marry that by the way is is
like you know the people who you're
talking to I'm kind of assuming that you
kind of you know you look like on some
level you got to relate to them and they
got a relate to you you know I'm saying
so if you are trying to speak to an
audience that you you don't know then it
really makes things hard so yeah okay
ket Kumar wants to make his own YouTube
channel do you have guidance tips advice
and then I guess maybe from like a
copyright in perspective yeah what do
you think in terms of making videos okay
that's I you know what that that is
something that I can give you a good a
copywriters perspective so the first
thing you want to do is what are you
about like what like if I give you four
seconds three seconds can you see can
you distill your message down to that
can you distill your message down to
essentially one sentence and marketing
speak that's called an elevator pitch
okay so it's actually one of the things
that I integrate into every form of
marketing every form of copy that I
write is a every form of copy I write is
like it's an elevator pitch right so how
you do that is you gotta say this is who
I am and this is this is who I help and
this is how I help them right so if you
are you know I don't know if he can
communicate with watch what it is that
she specifically does is she there uh
you can you know
cat if you want to add more in the
comments I'll try to keep my eye out for
it but I get three sick a little bit
okay that's cool she's up if if you're
into interior decorating you get to see
you you want to say hey this is who I
help this is how I help them this does a
couple of things right this immediately
lets everybody know who's included and
excluded from from the discussion and it
immediately gives people a reason to
want to communicate with it immediately
gives the the audience a kind of a
conversation point that says hey this is
what we're about and we connect together
because you helped me get this right so
if I said for example off the top of my
head I help business owners get clear
powerful and profitable communication
that's what my unique selling
proposition might be and then I can
brand around my unique selling
proposition so everything that your
brand becomes kind of embodies and like
kind of personifies what your unique
proposition what your elevator pitch is
so if you can say I help X person do Y
thing then you can kind of say oh I'm
the so-and-so person right I'm the you
know Evan Carmichael's believe that's
his brand right because he helps
entrepreneurs believe and achieve and
succeed in what what it is that they're
trying to do like I'm making a PSP right
now but in a sense that's kind of what
it is right
you're his brand is kind of like a
metaphor for his unique selling
proposition so you want to create a
brand but you want to create it based on
a very clear premise and then from there
everything reflects back to that core
message yeah for me if you're starting a
YouTube channel so you mean you click a
mine we have 200 something thousand
subscribers almost three hundred one the
foundation store is super important I
mean Anton touched on this before
talking about your story I remember when
I was working with my agent to work on
my
story I did it 20 30 times and you kept
making me redo it and redo it and redo
it until I had it down so super
important and then also from I mean I
guess back to the topic of this video
about creating copy that sells in
YouTube the title is super important and
the thumbnail is also super important
right so in somebody's searching like
you're gonna look at the picture before
you're gonna look at the the copy but
still is important so you know when when
aunt and I were making this session I
said hey anthem what do you want to call
this session right what are we going to
title it what's the name because it's
important right I want to reflect what
he thought it was about but also to have
a name that would attract attention and
so if you look at any search term the
videos that show up and that do well are
not just the ones that have the search
term in it it's not just like a stuffing
of search terms it's the ones that have
a powerful message and a powerful
thumbnail around that topic so
everything Anton said plus honestly is
funny I love how you were just like I
went on the big macro brand yourself and
then ya write a headline that you know
that that immediately you know draws an
attention give somebody a good reason to
want to click your videos right and
videos headlines just like a quick off
the top of my head a good headline
should offer something valuable it
should be specific so don't say how to
make more money it could be how to you
know save 20% on a restaurant tips or
whatever I don't know it could be
something that sparks curiosity that
type of thing so I'll land the plane on
that one
cool so I mean it's both it's the big
picture and in the tactical things I
like it um Ricardo is asking about our
thoughts on applying this to network
marketing how would you apply Network
yeah okay let me think about
example uh just a client that I I did a
direct mail letter I don't know I don't
know how does he Network for his network
marketing is what I my first question I
would say that I don't know if your car
is gonna respond so I'm just gonna
hypothesize so you know I I just I just
wrote a direct mail letter last week for
not a network marketer but an insurance
guy okay so this insurance guy is trying
to sell a service right and instead of
saying hey I can help you save more
money on your insurance and this is like
a letter going out to people in the mail
and this guy happened to sell very very
very high insurance so basically sells
to the board members of condominium
associations it's like talk about
someone who doesn't want to be spammed
at write someone who doesn't want to
deal with a lot of pesky buzzards and
that type of thing right well we in that
letter we were just like a one-page
letter and the letter was actually
formatted so that when it gets printed
out it's basically a handwritten letter
so it's really personal and that tells a
personal story about one of his
customers who they what happened they
got his granddaughter got fell and
bumped her head and how that related to
his to get buying insurance for the or
getting the right kind of insurance for
condominium associations right so you
you know you you're still using the
power of telling stories you're still
using that specific language you're
being benefit oriented all the nice
short stories like one example situation
I look at network marketing and I think
most people get in it for the wrong
reasons I think most people see if it's
as an income opportunity and have not
attached to the product I think the big
thing that we're marketing is you have
to tell your story as to why this works
like for you have it something that you
would proudly recommend you
mother using because you believe in it
so much and so there are some people who
are highly successful network marketing
but I think I think it gets a bad rap
because of all the people get in just
trying to make money at it and then you
look at their about page and it's
terrible it's just a stock about page it
was given by the north marketing company
they don't have their picture on there
they don't their story on there and I
think the thing that makes you stand out
is how you actually use and love the
products and services that you're
selling back to our original point about
telling a powerful story around it like
if you are not using it and you can't
talk about the benefits personally
around it then you're not gonna have
success in any business network
marketing I just think too many people
when you're you're when you're an
entrepreneur you create a product or
service you're emotionally attached to
it where a lot of times in network
marketing people join and they don't
really care about the product you trying
to make money and that's when you fail
out I like to comment on what you just
said I think that what you said what
what I hear when you say that is
actually if you're doing network
marketing well why do I want to buy from
you specifically well the one way you
can differentiate yourself and make your
product completely unique is to say is
to show how your product benefits you
personally so I really you know I'm
echoing back what Kevin just said cool
miles is right in
what's the statue next to you Evan this
is Guan Yu from a book called three
kingdoms it's one of the most read books
in Chinese history you go check it out
he's one of the Warriors is a God in
China there's a whole story behind that
we don't need to get into it here but
we'll just leave it on the curious note
you can go look up long a new fortune is
writing is writing in what does Anton
charge for copywriting we do web design
and are always looking to add more value
to our clients web projects you can
check my website there'll be a link to
that in the description of this video of
probably any of these videos if they're
small ones so gotta lead you there cool
yeah the link
site is their team wars writing in but i
want to become a copywriter topic was
you don't need to hire copywriter
he wants to become sure so so what
advice do you have for him who wants to
become a copywriter okay good question
super good question um my first up I'm
gonna break it down into a couple of
things first you got to know the craft
really well so you want to learn you
want to read you want to practice then
you want to get samples okay
read practice samples I'm glossing over
this really you know quickly but until
you have a basic skill set you are a
liability to yourself and your customer
okay when you have you know just a
little bit of practice you don't spend
too much time some people spend too much
time you know practicing I did they
don't spend enough time doing like
getting out there then you want to get
out there I'm gonna give you a simple
quick quick way to do that
get in your email inbox get just kind of
figure out all the people who you like
and follow in your subscriptions and
those are people who you've been
studying their product for a long time
you've had you interacted with their
product if you have no experience you
can make a list if you have a hundred
people that you subscribe to just reach
out to all of them and say hey um I am a
copywriter don't undersell yourself be
like I'm a beginner no you're a
copywriter you know I'm a copywriter I'm
just going through your website and
guess what I saw some stuff but I think
I can help like I think I can improve if
you want me to discuss that right there
those three things will get your foot in
the door I'm trying to think of how we
first met
to kind of give a example how did we
first connect was it over the LinkedIn
stuff I think you needed something you I
think you found you put out a job
somewhere I think it was on oDesk it was
and and I think we kind of
we came back we just like I think you're
really you're unique in that we've kept
in touch with vaguely over the years in
the background yeah but I'm saying so
you can also hit up some of the job
posting websites like I think it's up
work is what it's called now I didn't
mention that but it's a worthwhile place
to start I would recommend against
lingering there based on the fact that
you want to get more niche and more
specialized to the people you service
over time so you Lance is a great place
to find some good people or up work I
guess it's also a great place to find a
lot of nightmare clients so you want it
you want you can get in there to get a
quick jump let's just say so but I
didn't find it heaven was not hope I
wasn't nightmare I'm just thinking as an
example for people who want to get more
awareness of what they're doing I mean
we're here doing a hangout you're
answering questions I'm introducing you
to my audience I suggested it as an as
an opportunity because you wrote to me I
mean I haven't heard from you in a year
and so maybe more I miss that much yeah
and you wrote to me kind of the blue and
I said hey this is cool why don't we why
don't we do it as a as an interview and
let's chat about it and sure give you a
little more exposure to and help my
audience that I so I think developing
relationships to like if you could do
something if you can find people so back
to the question the teamwork if you can
find people who are who are influencers
in your space and work with them on
something it was a small project even if
it's a spec project it was a free watch
just to say oh I know who you are like
you you're on my radar now and maybe we
end up doing something like this and
then you get introduced to a lot of
other people and you can use that person
as a testimonial for your website hey
this person really helped me so look at
who you're to Anton's point about being
niche and specialize like okay so you
pick your niche who are the influencers
in that niche that then you can help out
whether it's just
you know helping them with their like
Twitter bio right it doesn't have to be
a long sales letter or page just
something quick and short that that can
help them in and develop a relationship
and that they like you know you trust
you they may give you jobs but they may
also refer you to other people so he's
writing in Anton thank you very much the
advice I'll absolutely do what you said
so there you go this is a quick a quick
a quick way to just like throw to boil
it down present yourself to people who
have influence without and offer them
some good value that can be a guest post
an interview that can be a critique of
their website that's a really great way
to get hired by the way to just say hey
oh man you're really messing up on your
website this is what I think you should
do and a lot of people will be grateful
for the free but valuable advice right
but actually give value not just like
hey you're messing up on your website I
can help you right because I get tons of
those like you me say this guy knows
what he's talking about you know you
don't to give away the whole thing but
give me a taste at least interested cool
world well we're already at time Anton I
appreciate you coming on and spending
time with us for people who there's you
know a lot of people have asked
questions here that we haven't gotten to
so I've linked up ant on his website in
the description and his Twitter account
is in the title any message or quick
thing you want to leave people with yes
if anyone wants some some some free
goodies I have I have an old from the
archive vault of an interview with me
interviewing with Evan and he is he gave
some really good advice on how to build
his business and that's just right on my
website so you can go into the
description below to find that also I
have a couple of really good goodies
good stuff that anyone who is an
entrepreneur might really love if they
just visited that site so I'm also happy
to answer any questions
cool well I appreciate it anton thank
you guys for watching
have a great day guys and we'll see you
soon